welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Edie Vigi tamale talbiya an assistant
professor of French at Yale University
her research interests include
francophone Maghrebi literature
post-colonial theory non-western
modernity's and transnational
modernism's she's published on north
african colonial and post-colonial
literature's and on issues of modernity
in European and non-european contexts
today we talk with her about her
forthcoming book the transcontinental
Maghreb francophone literature in a
Mediterranean context welcome Thank You
Marilyn for having me let us begin with
an overview of your book and it's
premise all right maybe I should talk a
little bit about this cope first okay
explain what I mean by Maghreb and
Mediterranean wonderful so the Maghreb
is the northern northwestern part of the
African continent that stretches the
Kempe stretch depending on definitions
from the western part of the continent
to West Western Canada Western Sahara
all the way to Libya and western Egypt
and the constant in this definition is
the presence of native populations known
in the West as Berbers okay
that would be the textbook definition
but my Maghreb is slightly different in
the sense that I work in the field of
francophone post-colonial studies and so
my Maghreb is the three former colonies
that France held dominion over in North
Africa
so Morocco Algeria and Tunisia okay and
so my book looks at this territory in
relation to the broader region of the
Mediterranean that stretches from the
Strait of Gibraltar to the west all the
way to the Middle East and Palestine
Lebanon and at the interactions between
the two so the premise of the book is
that in this corpus the corpus of
francophone Maghrebi literature that is
the literature written in
in the three former colonies French
colonies in North Africa there is a
Mediterranean ethos sort of submerged
ethos within this literature that my
project aims to excavate okay so the
Maghreb is a fascinating space for many
reasons but what really attracted me to
it is the polyphony and plurality of
cultures religions and languages since
within the Maghreb you find all three
monotheistic religions the Jews first of
all since very early on in fact ever
since before the fall of the Second
Temple so a very old old standing
presence then Islam starting in 649 AD
and Christianity as well both in the
days of the Roman Empire and in the
later days of European colonialism okay
so these three religions are present as
well as the number of languages and
dialects which makes it a particularly
rich cultural area and so my my premise
was really to try and look at this
diversity in the frame of the
Mediterranean and to harness this local
plurality to the broader narrative of
historical contact that existed not just
in the Maghreb but throughout the
Mediterranean starting starting from
ancient times okay and why don't you
feel it was important to write the book
well I felt that my argument allowed me
to address a number of issues that I
think are very relevant and pressing in
contemporary times the first one is this
issue of the Mediterranean in itself
what does it mean exactly
historically in this course is a Western
modernity the Mediterranean has been has
been pictured in different ways but
mostly the image that would be prevalent
was that of a fractured space between a
northern shore that would be European
and belong to that logic and then a
southern shore Islamic Arab Muslim that
would be the other Jews Europe and so my
idea by focusing on the on this region
this transnational space of the
Mediterranean was really to try and
build some kind of alternative discourse
and Reid admitted
Iranian differently alongside this
fractured vision of it so I thought that
it allowed me to really both examine and
critique this notion of the
Mediterranean the two notions of the
Mediterranean that we hear about very
often the first one being that of a
space as I said a fracture and that
would be prevalent in a clash of
civilization type of paradigm where you
look at Europe and the Arab world as
being two incommensurable spaces in
civilizations and then the other side of
the Mediterranean which I'm really
interested in which is the Mediterranean
as a space of mediation and so a space
that would that would of course obey
fractured and a symmetrical logic but
also a logic of cooperation and
collaboration between the two Shores so
I was interested I thought it was
important in fact to investigate both
readings of the Mediterranean and then
on the Maghrebi side of things
I I was interested in trying to find
alternative readings of culture and
identity that would not necessarily
restrict the Maghreb to either a sort of
Penn Arab history with Islam the Arabic
language and a kind of formatted
nationalist sense of identity on the one
hand and on the other hand the relation
between the Maghreb and France I wanted
to see what existed beyond this been
Arab or Franco Maghreb you logic and so
this kind of plural disjunctive reading
of the Maghreb as a Mediterranean space
allowed me to add another dimension to
this discourse how did you do your
methodology well I think that I was very
careful in fact not to impose any kind
of preconceived notion of this trope of
the Mediterranean to really take it
differently at different stages in the
book different moments so the book is
succession of chapters of course that
each focus on one specific moment that
are very specific and that have very
marked idiosyncrasies and so it starts
in the 30s with the school of Algiers
which was a school of writing that
emerged in the Algerian capital around
a number of figures very famous ones
like a deaf community Manuel Robles
Gabriela diesel and then I traced this
throughout the nationalist period in the
50s with deep and Khattab and then in
the 70s and 80s the moments of
disillusion and then in the contemporary
period mm-hm and so I tried for each one
of those chapters to really focus on the
specificities of this moment and to try
to let the text speak to me in a way and
to see where I was getting just looking
at the literature at the cultural
context and so the methodology in this
regard was not necessarily unified but
tried to take each context separately so
what it meant in terms of research was
of course a lot of time in the archive
because I had to go and explore
especially the earlier moments the 30s
the 40s not everything is accessible
easily and so I had to travel I had to
travel to Europe quite a bit to France
to Spain because my original project
also incorporated a little bit of
Spanish in it and so I had to go and
look at periodicals from the from the
time period of different journals and to
see what those authors were writing in
these other media which were very
popular in those days okay and how does
your research differ from other work
that has been done during this time
period I know you touched it a little
bit earlier but can you can you
elaborate on that yes yes a number of
people are talking about the
Mediterranean this days it's one of
those catch-all categories that
everybody seems to be banding about so I
think that it was very important for me
methodologically actually to elaborate
on the previous question to to look at
things to look at the Mediterranean not
just as a geographical space or a theme
so not just text that would be about the
Mediterranean but to look at the
Mediterranean as a heuristic tool or a
specific aesthetic so as a trope
something that would have philosophical
political aesthetic implications and to
try to have this kind of complex and
layered understanding of it so that the
Mediterranean wouldn't just become
another name for diversity or for Franco
Maghrebi crossings which
what a lots of these works end up being
about just another way of looking at how
France and the Maghreb intersect and I
wanted to go beyond I wanted to take
this logic to a trance now onto a
transnational plane and to try to
diffract the paradigm a little more so
that's one first difference the other
difference that I would point out is
that I try to do things styie
chronically starting as I sat with the
30s and tracing it back all the way to
the present and a number of very
contemporary concerns such as
clandestinity the clandestine illicit
migration from Africa and North Africa
to Europe these issues of no more ISM
that have been that have been really
adapted to the contemporary context of
illegal migration and those tragedies
that we read about in the in the
newspapers every day so in this sense I
tried to keep some kind of historical
continuity in it and the last main
difference I would say is that so this
is one book but this is part of a bigger
project and I always try to have an
approach that emphasizes not just French
and Arabic which are the main two
languages of the Maghreb but also other
languages or other idioms and so this
project is technically only about
francophone literature literature
written in French but the last chapter
for instance also includes other
languages and in the and the rest of the
chapters throughout I really try to look
at the way that French intersects with
other cultures other other norms of
their other traditions other idioms as I
said and so it's not just about one
language it's really a plurilingualism
that I am adopting to look at this
corpus okay and what have what have you
found what are some of your conclusions
well one of the things that actually
struck me when I did the research was
the extent to which this trope was
absolutely central to the corpus and
it's son not something that I
anticipated really I knew that it was
very crucial in colonial days because it
was a very easy way to deflect the issue
of
nationalism and whether or not algeria
since most of these people were in
algeria should be independent and so for
cami for instance the mediterranean was
a very very convenient conceptual way
out of this bind since he chose refused
the possibility of independence and
colonialism was becoming untenable so in
the thirties it was understood that i
would find this almost everywhere that i
looked but what I wasn't expecting was
to find it so clearly marked at
different times throughout the history
of the region cultural history of the
region for instance when well in the
contemporary period obviously we've
talked about this across the fields I
think this this obsession almost with
the time for instance of Al Andalus you
know the seventh century rule Arab and
Berber rule over parts of Europe which
year has been really focused on the
Andalusian space as a space of living
together of coexistence can be lengthy
and Spanish and this idea that somehow
it is part of the Maghrebi history and
so in the 90s especially in Algeria
there is this tendency for authors who
do not accept the state of things the
black decade what what has been called a
black decade which is an effective civil
war between Islamists on the one hand
and the power in place the probe rock on
the other and who saw in this Andalusian
utopia a sort of space where another
understanding of identity and culture
could be articulated and so it's it
remained very relevant and very current
all the way to today in fact so that's
one of the things I was really surprised
about another conclusion is that the
Mediterranean is really it evolves very
much it's it's not one single one single
trope it is something that has gone
through history and that can be either
utopian or dystopian for instance that
this is another thing that I wasn't
necessarily necessarily expecting to
find especially in light of what it was
in the 30s and the 40s but this
especially in the recent moment
clandestinity and clandestine crossing
it has become the space of dystopian so
I thought it was important to balance
both representation okay and I know this
is your book is part of a larger
research project that you're working on
tell us a bit about that yes yes well
the project I think all of my projects
there are several really have this
thread in common which is again the
Maghreb and the Mediterranean and the
interface between the two what the other
projects do that this one doesn't do too
much is look at other languages other
corpora and Spanish Italian a number of
dialects event of southern Europe on the
one hand Arabic French of course and
then try to have this kind of pleura
cultural and proof Lurie lingual
approach to things one of the questions
that I think I'm getting more and more
interested in is this idea of diaspora
and this idea of mobility and so getting
out of the Maghreb per se when you look
at what happens when people cross the
sea into Europe to go to France but also
to go to other territories that are not
necessarily historically linked to the
Maghreb and thinking of the Netherlands
for the connection there to America the
United States and I'm interested in
seeing what those non-standard tragic
Tories mean and how they could force us
to rethink our critical practices and so
at the intersection of this plural
plural angle lens and then this interest
in non-standard diasporic patterns I
actually started getting interested in
the production of a certain certain
community of North African authors in
Europe who have decided to write in
other languages than French and Arabic
yes and so they write an Italian in
Catalan in Spanish that's just for the
Mediterranean zone which I am interested
in but if you take it further you find
production in German in Dodge in English
so that is something that is really
under studied at the moment that I think
has a lot of potential and so in fact I
will be holding a conference here at
Yale on this very topic that I think
might be of interest to reviewers yeah
which is going to be cold beyond French
new languages for African diasporic
literature that I'm organizing in
partnership with Mike
professor Christopher Miller was a
professor of French and African and
african-american studies here at Yale
and that will examine this corpus so
corpus written by African authors who
have moved to Europe but not necessarily
to France and who have chosen chosen
other languages of expression than
French or their local native languages
so it will take place in March the last
weekend in March 29th and 30th of March
in the spring it is sponsored by two
councils at the Macmillan Center the
African Studies Council and the Center
on Middle Eastern Council Surrealists
and studies as well as the Kampf on and
a number of national literature
departments and it will gather together
in Everest colors from all three
continents the US Africa and Europe for
two days of panels film screenings
discussions and finally a beautiful
round table with three authors Laila
Laila me who is the Moroccan author who
writes in English who has gained a lot
of Fame here and whose collection of
short stories in particular hope and
other dangerous pursuits is now one of
the men's days of any almost any
syllabus and postcolonial Anglophone
literature in this country she'll be
here talking about her choice to write
in English to leave Morocco yes then pop
Kumar who is a Senegalese after writing
in Italian and who has become one of the
most prominent voices of this new
Italian African Italian community back
in Italy and rashida Elam rabbit who is
a Moroccan as well but a Berber this
time who brides in Dutch from Belgium
Wow and who has two novels who have
garnered award as well and who are being
very very important this new literary
landscape very exciting will have the
Fleur to that yes well thank you very
much for being here and sharing some of
your work Thank You Marilyn for having
me was a pleasure okay for more
information about Professor talam a
Talib I EV and her research please visit
our website at Yale gdu slash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Centre for
International and Erised
yeah